all right let's go to william in
lexington kentucky
william how we doing brother i'm doing
fine and you dr
john man i'm getting it you just made my
hearts of my heart sing a little bit man
how long have you been in kentucky uh
since 92 that's right outstanding well
brother how can i help you this morning
well i recently found out and um
i'm i'm really upset about this i
recently found out that my
uh 30 middle 30 year old son
is in an open marriage okay
how'd you find out well one night we
were sitting at
he was in my home and we were talking
and uh he shared that with my wife and i
and justin was it just as an off-site
just hey what's your favorite movies oh
by the way guys i'm in an open marriage
i mean or did he sit down and say hey i
need to talk to you all about something
no no it just popped up like uh just a
little bit of trivia
wow uh the next morning
after i had you know essentially settled
down a little bit
um i told him that that
i will always love him but i will never
approve of an open marriage
and so that went on for maybe a month
and then i went up to his home and he
and i sat down and spoke
and i prefaced my talk with you know i
will always love you you will always be
my son i will respect your wife because
you chose her
but i will never approve of your open
marriage
and he admitted to it that he's in an
open marriage
and apparently he's been in an open
marriage since they've been married for
three years
and to make a long story short he
essentially what he said was
i will go with people that still love me
no matter what i do and so essentially
he canceled me out
so my question to you is where do i go
from here
where do you want to go man
well i will never approve of an open
marriage
right um my judeo-christian beliefs will
not allow me to do that there's just no
way in the world
hey brother i'm telling you common sense
tells you it's not a good idea right
no i i'm a christian guy too i share
your values there but there's just
common sense right
so i i i shared with him that there was
a 90
92 chance of they will get a divorce
they will always have trusted trust
issues
if they they do not have any children
but if they have children
then who's going to be the father you
know
all those things we we spoke of all
those things so let's let's back out a
little bit
this is a hard question i'm going to ask
you okay
okay did he come to you to ask for your
approval
yes and so he when he sat down with you
he said dad i want your blessing on this
well essentially before we met the last
time
he sent me various articles in support
of an open marriage oh good god so he's
trying to uh
convert you yeah okay
so he sought your opinion you gave it to
him he didn't like what you had to say
and he said well philly on you correct
okay and so when he says i'm i'm
canceling you out old man
does that mean he doesn't want you to
come around does that mean he says i'm
never coming to your house you and
mama's house again what
what does that mean yes he doesn't want
to come to the house he doesn't want to
be around us
because in his last text to me
he said that he has christian friends
that support what they do and that's who
he will
reciprocate his love to okay
had that text hit you
well i would like to meet the christian
friends i would too man
i would too but but
put those friends aside put those
thoughts and ideas aside how did that
hit you
i didn't like it but i'm not going to
sell out to the devil
to to gain uh the favor of my son
okay so where you find yourself is is
this
you've got some principles and values
that you're standing firm on
you made a commitment and values
and stances often come at a cost
and i don't know that there's a greater
cost than losing connection with your
son
and i don't think you lost that
connection i think your son asked you
for your
thoughts and opinions you gave them and
then he made a decision to walk away
and as a parent of a child
you're a parent i mean you're not a
parent of a child you're a parent of a
grown man
he's 30 you say he's 36
yeah he's he's he's 36 he's almost 40
years old
he's making a decision to walk away
based on he's throwing a grown-up temper
tantrum saying i don't want to be around
my daddy because i have just different
opinions in him
and he's he's just selecting to walk him
walk out
and that leaves you two options go
running after him
and say honey honey honey or to say my
door is always open for you my car door
is always open i will get in and come
visit you
i'll come hang out i will love you but
if he chooses to walk away from you
he chooses to walk away from you yeah
and
that's heartbreaking and that stinks i
mean you're in an either or choice right
now
actually you're not man i'm thinking
this as out loud as i'm talking
he's making the call dude yes
and it's his decision to make that's
right so here's what you need to do
you need to this and this is probably
not a popular thing
for older gentlemen in um kentucky
all right and i just made a gross
generalization and all the people from
kentucky can send me
me mean cards and letters i understand
but listen
you are gonna have to grieve the
separation of your son
because where this is really quickly
going to turn in your heart and mind if
you don't deal with it it's going to
turn into bitterness
it's going to turn into anger and it's
going to be like that old a.a
saying which is you're going to be
poisoning yourself hoping somebody else
dies
correct you're going to have to grieve
the fact that your son
and you have different opinions on open
marriages or closed marriages
and that he chose to walk away from you
because he didn't appreciate what you
had to say
he is choosing friends over dad
yes at this time that's correct i want
you to hear me though will
that that hurts and that stinks and i'm
sorry
yes it does hurt but um
listen i'm a man of principle you are
but but behind that principle behind
that principle
is a daddy yeah and then i don't want
you to miss that
because behind principle and behind
values
are people and sometimes we stand really
strong on principles we stand really
strong on values
and we ignore that dad that remembers
playing catch with his boy
and you gotta honor that guy too it's
okay to have principles and values and
it's okay to be sad
those aren't incompatible okay and what
i'm telling you is if you don't honor
the sadness
if you don't honor the grief that your
son chose to bail on you for a season
and i think you're right he's going to
come back he knows his old man loves him
i think he's going to circle back but if
you don't grieve that it will turn to
bitterness and it will
crush you okay
well i've shared it with my with my
sisters
and uh it's it's not something that i
have kept to myself
right because historically i have found
when i
when i tend to internalize things like
not like that but internalize things
that
stress me or cause me stress then it
becomes worse
and so from the point from the from the
get-go
i shared with my my sisters and they
felt
you know they it just felt good to get
it out
yes sir good good stay in contact with
them and don't be afraid to
not rally people around a year support
you
but don't be afraid even if you got to
text him it's not the best way to do it
but even if you got to text him
text your sisters text a friend an old
buddy
and just say i miss my son today and i'm
sad
i'm going to be all right but today i
just woke up and i miss my son
i'm sad and
to all of the dads and the sons and the
moms and the daughters out there
man be careful about cancelling
relationships
even if you disagree even if you all
have core
virtue issues
man love your parents
even if they think differently than you
even if they try to give you wisdom i
know when you're 20 and 30 you think you
know everything and i figure out this
new solution to this and this and i want
to go run
feel good over here and man
i'm telling you even if they don't know
how to say it right your moms and dads
love you
i have yet to see the data that open
marriage solves anything
i haven't seen it i don't think it's a
good idea i think it's a terrible idea
i wish people would sit down and have
deeper harder conversations with their
spouses
about what they want what they need from
one another that's a whole other
different conversation
and that's what this call presented as
that's not what this call was about this
call is about a dad who's got some firm
principles who was honest with his son
son came to him and said hey dad what do
you think about this and his dad said
i think that's not a wise decision son i
don't i don't think that's wise at all
i think you're going to end up hurt i
think you're going to end up in a mess
and i love you and i don't want you to
be in a mess and i don't want to see you
hurt
and his son threw a temper tantrum took
his ball and went home
and said fine daddy i've got other
friends who who are different than you
they'll let me just do whatever i want
and they'll high-five me and say
you do you you go you you take care of
you
man those aren't friends man those
aren't friends